>>> SOLOMON PENA WILL BE IN
COURT FACING CHARGES HE
ORCHESTRATED SHOOTINGS THAT
DAMAGED HOMES OF DEMOCRATIC
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
HE CLAIMED ELECTION FRAUD
WITHOUT EVIDENCE AFTER LOSING BY
A LANDSLIDE LAST NOVEMBER.
THE STATE'S GOVERNOR TELLING CNN
SHE IS RELIEVED PENA IS IN
CUSTODY.
>> IT IS CHILLING TO REALIZE
THAT YOU HAVE A MEMBER OF YOUR
COMMITTEE WHO RAN FOR OFFICE WHO
USES THE SAME PROPAGANDA THAT
INSTILLS VIOLENT REACTIONS FROM
OTHERS THEN PERSON PE TRAITS,
ORCHESTRATES, AND DIRECTS WHAT
QUITE SIMPLY WAS THE
ATTEMPTED -- IT WASN'T JUST
HARASSMENT, POTENTIAL MURDER OF
INNOCENT VICTIMS ACROSS THE
CITY.
IT MAKES ANYONE RUNNING FOR
OFFICE TERRIFIED.
>> CNN'S KYUNG LAH HAS MORE FROM
ALBUQUERQUE.
>> ONE CAME RIGHT THROUGH HERE
AND THEN WE'VE GOT THE REST OVER
HERE.
>> Reporter: ABOUT A DOZEN
BULLETS EMBEDDED IN THE OUTSIDE
OF DEBBY O'MALLEY'S HOME.
>> I WAS VERY ANGRY AND JUST
DISGUSTED ABOUT THE WHOLE THING.
>> THESE ARE SIGNIFICANTLY SIZED
HOLES.
>> THEY ARE.
IT WAS SO LOUD.
THIS HAPPENED WHEN MY HUSBAND
AND I WERE ASLEEP.
>> Reporter: O'MALLEY
IMMEDIATELY SUSPECTED WHO THE
GUNMAN MIGHT BE, THIS MAN.
>> HI.
MY NAME IS SOLOMON PENA.
CAN I SPEAK WITH DEBBY O'MALLEY.
>> Reporter: SOLOMON PENA WENT
TO HER DAUGHTER'S ADDRESS AND
THEN HER HOME A MONTH BEFORE THE
SHOOTING.
THIS IS HIM ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE FENCE.
>> HE SEEMED AGITATED.
HE SEEMED A LITTLE AGGRESSIVE TO
ME.
I DIDN'T CONSIDER HIM A THREAT
THEN BUT HE WAS UPSET THAT HE
HAD LOST THE ELECTION.
>> Reporter: POLICE ARRESTED HIM
MONDAY IN CONNECTION WITH A
STRING OF WHAT THEY CALL
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED SHOOTINGS
OF FOUR DEMOCRATIC LEADERS IN
NEW MEXICO.
NO ONE WAS INJURED.
>> IT IS BELIEVED THAT HE IS THE
MASTERMIND THAT WAS BEHIND THIS.
>> Reporter: POLICE SAY HE'S
SUSPECTED OF HIRING A CONTRACTOR
FOR CASH TO COMMIT AT LEAST TWO
OF THE FOUR SHOOTINGS, FROM
DECEMBER 4th TO JANUARY 3rd.
PENA WAS A REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
FOR STATEHOUSE SEAT AND HE SPENT
YEARS IN PRISON FOR BURGLARY AND
LARCENY.
THE JUDGE ALLOWED THE CONVICTED
FELON TO BE ON THE GROUND
CALLING IT UNCONSTITUTIONAL TO
ALLOW PENA THE DENIAL TO SERVE.
>> HE LOST IN NOVEMBER BY A
LANDSLIDE THEN ACCUSED HIS
OPPONENT OF RIGGING THE
ELECTION.
WEARING A MAGA SWEATSHIRT, PENA
TWEETED HE STANDS WITH TRUMP AND
HE NEVER CONCEDED HIS OWN RACE
IN NEW MEXICO.
ELECTION DENIALISM.
>> THERE'S SOME SHENANIGANS
GOING ON.
>> THAT HE HEARD IN TRUMP
RALLIES LIKE THIS ONE IN PHOENIX
IN 2021.
PENIA TWEETED THIS PICTURE
SAYING HE CAMPED OUT ALL NIGHT
TO SEE TRUMP.
PHOTOGRAPHS SHOW PENA PICTURED
WITH THIS MAN.
THE WARRANT ALLEGES HE IS ONE OF
THE SUSPECTED SHOOTERS ARRESTED
WITH A GUN USED IN ONE OF THE
SHOOTINGS.
POLICE SAY PENA TEXTED THE HOME
ADDRESSES OF FOUR TARGETS TO
FOUR SUSPECTS TO CARRY OUT THE
SHOOTINGS AND IN AN EXCHANGE
TEXTED THEY JUST CERTIFIED IT.
THEY SOLD US OUT TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER.
THEY WERE LITERALLY LAUGHING AT
US WHILE THEY WERE DOING IT.
>> EVERYBODY IS MORE WORRIED
NOW.
>> ADRIAN BARBEAU A WAS ALSO
TARGETED.
FOUR BULLETS RIPPED THROUGH HER
HOME INTO THE ROOM WHERE SHE HAD
JUST BEEN PLAYING WITH HER
GRANDDAUGHTER.
>> IT MAKES ME ANGRY THAT ONE
PERSON, MAKES ME ANGRY THAT WE
HAVE A FORMER PRESIDENT AND
CURRENT ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
HIGHEST LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT THAT
THINK IT'S OKAY TO INVOKE
VIOLENCE IN THESE SITUATIONS.
YEAH,S RANGE OF EMOTIONS BEING
HURT, SAD, DISAPPOINTMENT.
>> Reporter: DESPITE HOW
EMOTIONALLY DRAINING, SCARY THIS
HAS ALL BEEN, WHAT WE'RE NOT
HEARING FROM ANY OF THE VICTIMS
IS ANY OF THEM BACKING DOWN FROM
REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE IN
POLITICS AND IN GOVERNMENT.
PENA MAKES HIS FIRST COURT
APPEARANCE ON WEDNESDAY.
KYUNG LAH, CNN, ALBUQUERQUE, NEW